je tiens à dire que cette émission le
passé sur france 2 juste avant même
qu'ils aient qui se veut en quelque
quelques à la première fois que j'ai
rencontré rocco siffredi je lui dis en
vue d'une interview un peu comme sa
carte d'identité disons à jeudi tata il
me répond tout de suite 25 centimes à
dire pas du tout pensé à autre chose
alors vous à l'heure qu'il est on peut
en parler qu'à cette heure et demie du
soir en plus je réponds toujours bas de
la taille moyenne des français 18 cm en
bas vous dit ça en gros 10 juniors où
j'avais 19 ans il ya mieux moi je vis
avait pendant la fille parfois s'allonge
un peu plus pourquoi lors de l'émission
qui est qui quand la fille vous dit la
question dont vous seul arrêt un jeune à
marie ange nardi pourquoi quand elle
vous dit pourquoi vous répondez ça c'est
insensé quand même je sais pas parce que
man et les questions à poser mais c'est
vraiment vrai alors c'est une question
qu'on vous a jamais pu gêner jolie
peut-être ça nous a fait penser à ça
aussi non non je n'en dirai joli nom non
pas spécialement
ça s'est passé jeudi
j'aime bien marié ange nardi elle est
mignonne mais je dire c'est pas ça qui
m'a fait penser à la meilleure jeune à
redire à mercredi
mais non je ne sais pas c'est parce que
c'est vrai qu'on n'a jamais c'est la
question c'est qu'est-ce qu'on n'a
jamais osé vous poser je vais pas parce
qu'on n'a jamais fait des missions
ensemble c'est tout il ya longtemps
qu'ils voudraient demandé alors dans les
vestiaires de la patinoire dans sa
cellule qu'ailleurs
ya beaucoup de choses à raconter ya même
un film à faire donc on va y arriver à
la carte de monsieur alors mais depuis
qu'il entraîne
oui à la londe alors pour moi pour mon
pognon comme ça les moyens d'aider même
quand même non peut être van damme s'est
offert un flux de tweets fruits et du x
à l'accord du vix tout de suite vous
êtes prêt à même marié les 18 ans
allongé un peu plus moi j'y crois moi on
m'a toujours dit à moi toujours du beau
tu es bien sûr ternera parce que tu es
grosse que oui mais c'est pas c'est pas
c'est par aux montres a eu des grands
acteurs d'alix comme les et qu'ils
avaient au contraire même 15 au 14 et ça
ne saoule tout comme tu le fais bon on
met parfois moi je défie qui m'ont dit
assez trop grand ça va me faire mal leur
sac et a refusé vous savez ça leur
sinclair a refusé jeudi par anne
sinclair
lorsque claire a refusé de jeu jusqu'à
ma mort mais heureusement heureusement
la plus la plus grands peuples deux fois
contre la france a décidé de la faire
ouais ils m'ont jamais dit les bleus
avant que c'est alors qu'est ce que vous
dites c'est que les films pornos sont à
la portée de toutes les bourses
je te les bulls ça dépend comme tu le
fait d'al qaïda mais sûrement la chose
plus important c'est la passion que tu
mets dedans voilà ce que vous dites là
c'est une très bonne nouvelle parce que
philippe candeloro dit quand on lui dit
vous gagner beaucoup d'argent et dit
attendez moi je vais terminer entraîneur
à dix mille balles par mois donc si je
peux prendre de l'argent maintenant je
vais pas me le reprocher vous êtes est
une autre façon de vous reconvertir un
prévôt pourquoi pas viser pourquoi il ne
disait rien de salace parce qu'il ya en
fait il est trop jeune maman profs des
films pornos c'était plus alban al roba
le cancer et bien sûr
c'est vrai que les films pornos bon
roberto malone et étendant sa mère on se
ressemble
prêté lui les plus âgés mais on a
commencé à regarder maintenant il est
fait je fais plus c'est quelque chose là
avec ma femme qui est à regarder la
télévision quoi c'était à vous le fais
ton vrai quoi ouais enfin je fais pas
les films mais vous pourrez vous faites
si les films pas non non non pas encore
des questions à l'artiste favori ça
détend vous avez un nom mais voilà donc
c'est une nouvelle carrière devant vous
pourquoi pas mais mon avis avec ma femme
ça risque d'être dur quand même
pourquoi elle veut pas mais pourquoi
avec good femmes bon cinéma
après c'est moi c'est un état d'esprit
après lula sûrement je les connais
heureux de savoir qu'après sept ans de
mariage vous amuser toujours beaucoup
avec olivia basse et bien c'est le bio
c'est bien sûr la dernière question une
petite dernière question de vous restez
avec nous une petite dernière question
excuse dans le patin est de la daube
comme dans le vélo que dernières
éditions on a vu à roanne menthéour qui
nous ont raconté des biens belles est ce
que dans le patin il ya deux le p ô des
corticoïdes eux en fait mon dans le
patinage c'est quand même un sport assez
particulier se doper vous ne pourrez
servir à long terme sans l'entraînement
pour faire des charges de travail à
beaucoup plus intense mais sur le moment
de la compétition là où il faut être le
plus fort c'est mentalement c'est pas
c'est pas physiquement ni techniquement
parce que le mental fait tout un
dernière c'est le mental c'est comme
rocco c'est pas comme c'est le mental
qui sont bien des problèmes ne se lave
pas napolitaine des lots 4 ce nouveau
plaisir
ouais le chat ne pas sortir non ça veut
dire de l'accueil veut pas de procès est
par essence qu'il faut vraiment pour
fêter à la belgique et un en face rien
de tout
il faut oublier tout le reste ouais
c'est le mental tranche napolitaine
c'est des métiers basées sur mon talent